I can't believe this is happening we've
We've joked about this we were kidding
it was just a joke a new report finds
that Donald Trump is considering Carey
Lake to be his vice president in his
2024 presidential campaign
um I
I don't know where to start axios
reports scoop Kerry Lake among Four
Women Trump is considering for VP pick
former president Trump is strongly
considering picking a female running
mate and sees Carrie Lake as a model for
his vice presidential pick according to
people who have discussed it with him
um Lake of course is the former TV
anchor she lost her race for governor in
November
Trump believes one of his weaknesses is
white Suburban women that he's going to
need white Suburban women to defeat
President Biden and so the thought is
what about Lake now what are her
qualifications well axios I mean this
isn't this isn't satire from axios but
it is a joke in the in the sense that
it's wild that this is what's going on
lake has shown she's willing to defend
Trump vociferously no matter the issue
or controversy that's true she's a true
believing sycophant that's absolutely
true
Trump's friends to the extent he has any
say that Kerry lake has a big downside
he wants no risk that is running running
mate could outshine him and Lake would
be assumed to be angling for president
from the day she enters the White House
she even went to Iowa last month and of
course losing her winnable Governor's
race hurts her Mojo
wow now Trump is considering four women
who else is there there's Nikki Haley
who is running against him and uh Trump
apparently believes she won't take any
votes from him so she's not really a
danger
another idea is Arkansas governor Sarah
Huckabee Sanders who was Trump's White
House Press Secretary
that's uh pretty wild and then fourth is
South Dakota governor Christy gnome
who's often mentioned by Trump
confidants although I don't know that
she carries the
faux gravitas of uh of of Carrie Lake uh
I can't believe this is real life but it
is true and of course when you step back
you say she has an unblemished record of
never winning anything she's a complete
Trump suckup she lies uncontrollably and
constantly that seems like it would make
her a bad candidate but that actually is
seen as making her a good candidate now
that being said I think it's important
to be bearing in mind that Trump could
win could win with anyone as VP and
Carrie Lake being that close to the
presidency is truly horrific stuff so
there's two perspectives on this and
this is the same sort of question that
came up during my interview yesterday
with Adam Schiff which is on the one
hand you and I look at Carrie Lake and
we say oh my goodness that's more of a
joke than Sarah Palin it would be
terrible for Trump at the national level
we should hope that he picks someone as
crazy as Carrie Lake
the Counterpoint is
Trump could win
and there is going to be no guarantee if
Trump is the nominee that Trump will be
defeated in November of 2024. do we
really want to risk Kerry Lake becoming
the vice president and then being a
Heartbeat Away from the presidency
because we think it would hurt Trump's
chances or is it simply too much risk
now of course at the end of the day it's
not up to us it's up to Republican
primary voters but what started as a
joke it really was just oh you know
Marjorie Taylor green and Kerry Lake are
angling to be Trump's VP but it's just a
joke that's all it is The Insider scoop
is that Kerry lake is not only being
considered she's only one of four being
considered and quite frankly seems to be
more of a front-runner based on her
level of sycophancy than a bunch of
these other people
truly horrifying stuff but this seems to
be the direction that Trump is going
one of our sponsors is Helix sleep I
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
at home for years now I couldn't be more
happy with it I recommend it to
everybody the other day even though
she's not allowed in the big bed I put
my baby daughter on the mattress and
even she loved it Helix sleep is the
premium mattress brand offering tailored
mattresses based on your unique sleep
preferences take the Helix sleep quiz it
asks you about your body type your
sleeping position do you get hot at
night do you have back pain and then
Helix will match you with the mattress
that's perfect for you most people don't
know where to begin when shopping for a
mattress including me Helix makes it
simple and less risky because you know
you're getting a mattress that fits your
needs it ships free you can try it for a
hundred nights to see if you like it and
it comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty
unlike many mattress companies all Helix
mattresses are made in the USA by a
skilled production team so you were
supporting good jobs helix sleep is
giving my audience up to 20 percent off
plus two free pillows what other
mattress company is going to give you 20
off go to helixsleep.com Pacman the link
is down below